a Florida woman is in a quintuple with
four men this was just chronicled on a
show called love don't judge here she is
this is Tori she fell in love with
Travis and Ethan and Mark and Chris
their four-way relationship is working
wonders for them the relationship could
best be described by HIV Torre as the
hub and all of us are spokes on the
giant wheel but not everyone understands
the dynamic I was like oh you're kidding
that you're joking how will this poly
relationship cope with a further
addition to the family and so who's the
father of the baby oh you think that's
weird
oh you think that's maybe not the best
thing and how dare you you bigot how
intolerant of you how phobic and ISM
that is both ISM and phobic that you're
doing of course not
of course not this is a cultural issue
right this woman is in a romantic
relationship that she wants to be
recognized culturally and one presumes
politically with four men simultaneously
they're having a child together they
don't know who the father of the baby is
there is a role for government here the
government has a an interest in
protecting children the government has
an interest in having a definition of
marriage the government has an interest
in this kind of social madness how did
this come about
if seven years ago eight years ago you
had said that this would be chronicled
that that this woman would have a
relationship with four guys I think a
lot of people would have said yeah maybe
there are a lot of weird people
especially no disrespect intended but
especially in Florida you see a lot of
headlines right except something
fundamentally changed about seven years
ago which is that
redefined marriage for the first time
ever we fundamentally redefined marriage
from a relationship between husbands and
wives to anything goes
we had a definition of marriage that had
endured in the West for all of certainly
recent memory but for our civilization
which is that one man marries one woman
and they have children together now that
has broken down we've expanded the
definition of marriage to include
monogamous same-sex unions why
monogamous if the whole argument for
redefining marriage to include
monogamous same-sex unions is love is
love and how dare you judge and the
heart wants what the heart wants
then who are you to exclude this woman
and her four creepy boyfriends from
marriage doesn't make any sense there
will be a political push to legalize
polygamy there already is in some
quarters and there is no limiting
principle on the Supreme Court's crazy
decision to redefine marriage because
Justice Kennedy woke up and felt like a
romantic poet one day so there will be a
major push for this and that is a
political issue obviously marriage our
families our cultural primarily but
there is a huge political aspect to this
there will be an answer what is marriage
there will be an end there will be a
political answer to that and if we
decide to blow open the doors to
marriage which in many ways we've
already done that is going to have
cultural effects if you enjoyed that
video be sure to hit the like button so
that the rest of the youtubes know that
our content is the best content